vous la dernière minute de la
prolongation du quart de finale de la
coupe du monde 2010 c'est la 120e minute
le score est encore un partout entre le
ghana et l'uruguay ce coup franc
excentré est sans doute le coup franc de
la dernière chance avant la séance de
tirs au but c'est bien tiré aussi
dangereux oh le sauvetage de soirée sur
sa ligne avec le pied et encore mais
c'est une main non stupeur dans le stade
l'arbitré n'hésite pas une seule seconde
carton rouge pour suarez et penalty pour
le ghana à ce mondial s'apprête à
envoyer le dernier pays africain de la
compétition en demi finale de la coupe
du monde un stade de la compétition qu
aucune équipe africaine n'a su atteindre
par le passé quatre mois diane seulement
la barre la barre la barre 1 l'arbitré
siffle la fin du match ghana et
l'uruguay sont encore à égalité la
qualification pour les demi finales se
jouera donc dans une séance de tirs au
but et le ghana finira par la paix est
le lendemain les journaux européens
crient au scandale
suarez incarne le diable c'est un voyou
sans respect mais en uruguay
suarez devient un héros national c'est
le soldat qui n'a pas hésité à se
sacrifier pour la gloire de son pays
alors soares anges ou thébaux est bien
en finale il s'agit avant tout d'un cas
où un joueur n'a fait que suivre ses
incentives suarez a fait ce qui était
bien pour lui et selon lui et d'ailleurs
il n'était pas le seul vouloir faire ce
qu'il a fait cette remarque est le
fondement de la théorie des jeux cette
branche des mathématiques qui
s'intéresse aux interactions entre
individus et institutions dans cette
théorie chacun fait ce qui est bien pour
lui et selon lui alors avant que vous ne
criez au scandale et pensiez qu'il
s'agit là d'une offense à la nature
humaine je précise que ce qui est bien
pour quelqu'un selon quelqu'un peut
parfaitement être altruiste d'ailleurs
suarez n'a pas fait ce qui était bien
pour lui lui ce qui était bien pour lui
selon lui était quelque chose de
relativement altruiste puisque il
préférait se faire expulser et voir les
siens gagner plus généralement les
patriotes sont ceux qui pensent que ce
qui est bien pour selon eux est le
triomphe de leur nation de leurs groupes
sociaux peu importe leur sort individuel
quand je dis que chacun fait ce qui est
bien pour lui et selon lui toutes les
valeurs éthiques et morales de la
personne en question mais aussi ses
croyances sur le monde qui l'entourent
sont contenues dans le pour lui et selon
lui est de façon cruciale comme nos
valeurs morales divergent d'une personne
à l'autre ce qui est bien pour et selon
un libertarien ne sera pas la même chose
que ce qui est bien pour et selon un
marxiste en fait quand on se demande si
quelque chose est bien ou mal ce nous
être un réflexe de théoriciens des jeux
que de se demander bien pourrait selon
qui l'or en général pour une personne
donnée c
difficile de savoir ce qui est bien pour
est selon elle quoique dans nos sociétés
il semble y avoir une préférence très
récurrente ce qui explique une grosse
partie de l'économie et du monde du
travail
en effet il semble que la plupart des
employés qu'ils soient technicien
manager pdg ou politiciens ne veulent
pas perdre leur job et incite possible
il préférerait monter dans la hiérarchie
du coup les agissements des techniciens
manager pdg ou politiciens seront
inéluctablement les conséquences de leur
désir de rester à leur poste et de
monter dans la hiérarchie et des
initiatives qui leur seront données pour
ce faire ainsi il est devenu extrêmement
courant de pointer du doigt les
politiciens les publicitaires et les
médias comme étant la cause de tous les
maux qui frappent nos sociétés si
seulement ces individus arrêter la
démagogie le pit a cliqué l'effet que
news si seulement il faisait preuve de
pédagogie et impartialité
si seulement ces individus se comporter
de manière éthique se dit on on pourrait
enfin vivre dans une société rationnelle
et optimisé qui ne chercherait pas été
informé le peuple stigmatiser ces
minorités et crée des besoins infondées
mais pour le théoricien des jeux ce we
shall fine thing est un voeu pieux non
pas parce qu'il est dans la nature
humaine de céder à des tentations
démoniaque
mais parce que dans ces milieux les
incentives sont ce qu'ils sont tout
individu de ces milieux qui dévie des
stratégies classiques et qui cherche à
se comporter comme le plus grand dessein
qui soit sera un politicien sans
supporters un publicitaire sans client
est un média 100 lecteurs
il ne sera plus que poussière dans ces
milieux de survivront que ceux qui
auront joué le jeu et tant que le jeu
n'aura pas changé
les actions des politiciens publicitaire
hi media ne changeront pas de bleus a
hissé le jeu pas les joueurs
je ne dis pas qu'il ne sert à rien de
promouvoir l'éthique et la morale et
d'ailleurs je trouve que les vidéos de
youtube cultural le font très bien
après tout il arrive que l'opinion du
grand public conduit au licenciement de
certains dirigeants
mais il ne faut pas perdre de vue que
plus le processus d'élimination des
joueurs non performants et intense plus
les joueurs qui seront encore en jeu
ceux qui répondent aux incentives plus
il ya de compétition plus les
techniciens manager pdg ou politicien
qu'il restera seront ceux qui sont
gouvernés par les incentives qui leur
sont données et ce principe explique
pourquoi certains dirigeants fraude et
pourquoi d'autres ne fraude pas comme
leurs employés ce que les dirigeants
désire avant tout c'est ne pas subir
l'humiliation du licenciement sans doute
parce que nous chrétiens de cerveau
exagère davantage les pertes qui le
célèbrent les gains hors effectuer une
fraude alors que tout va bien
augmente la probabilité de licenciement
en revanche quand les résultats de
l'entreprise compromettre grandement
leur avenir dans l'entreprise les
dirigeants auront un grand incentive à
frauder pour garder leur emploi
autrement dit théorie des jeux combinés
à la psychologie expérimentale prédit
que c'est en période de crise que les
comportements immoraux sont le plus
probable et cette prédiction théorique a
été confirmée empiriquement notamment
par des analyses de brousse bénodet
mesquita qui a pu observer que c'est
précisément lorsque les bénéfices des
entreprises sont au plus faible que les
fraudes des dirigeants sont les plus
fréquentes à hisser le jeu pas les
joueurs
si les techniciens manager pdg ou
politiciens font des choses que l'on
juge moralement mauvais ce n'est donc
pas que vis-à-vis d'eux qu'il faut sévir
c'est surtout le jeu qu'il joue qu'il
faut questionner or il me semble que
trop souvent on critique les joueurs et
on oublie le jeu c'est le cas par
exemple quand on identifie le
capitalisme et l'économie de marché aux
grands patrons du cac 40
en particulier il me semble que bien
souvent se focalise sur les grands
gagnants du jeu et on en vient à oublier
quelques propriétés fondamentales du jeu
comme le fait que la plupart des joueurs
l'économie ne sont pas à somme nulle
autrement dit en général ce qu'un joueur
gagne n'est pas ce qu'un autre paire
surtout en économie si monsieur lambda
achète un rouleau de pq à 5 euros à la
station service
c'est parce qu'au moment de l'achat le
rouleau de pq a plus de valeur à ses
yeux que ces 5 euros alors bien sûr on a
quand même envie de dire que monsieur
lambda s'est fait avoir d'une certaine
manière mais si l'on pense cela c'est
sans doute à cause de l'effet d'ancrage
dont sens étonnante vous a parlé dans sa
série crétin de cerveau on a tellement
pris l'habitude de payer beaucoup moins
pour du pq que l'on ne pense faire avoir
et y perdre à faire la transaction n'a
alors envie de ailleurs le vendeur est
une entreprise qui nous ont vendu le pq
et l'on va s'empresser de s'en plaindre
auprès de nos amis
cependant s'il échange commercial a bien
eu lieu
c'est bien parce que monsieur l'onda et
la station ils ont tous deux gagné au
change
analyser le jeu pas les joueurs on
reviendra plus longuement sur l'économie
des marchés ses bienfaits et ses
défaillances
ainsi que sur la négociation
mathématiques des prix plus tard dans
cette série sur la démocratie pour
l'heure étant donné l'actualité
j'aimerais que l'on implique l'analyse
des jeux à la politique
selon la théorie des jeux la question
qu'il faudrait de poser n'est pas si
chaque candidat est bon ou mauvais la
question qui importe ces cas sont les
incentives que notre système
démocratique impose aux hommes
politiques d'aujourd'hui
tout d'abord il faut bien voir que
surtout à l approche des élections
les hommes politiques ont avant tout
intérêt à dire ce que les citoyens
veulent entendre
ils ont avant tout intérêt à suivre
l'opinion publique et c'est en cela que
le système représentatif et au moins en
partie démocratique vous invite à garder
ça en tête lorsque les politiciens
disent ou font des trucs qui vous
déplaisent trop souvent quand un
politicien défend une idée démocratique
qui nous déplaît à tendance à critiquer
le politicien et à lui reprocher son
populisme ou cette démagogie
alors qu'il ne fait que dire ou faire ce
que le peuple veut
cependant pour acquérir l'adhésion d'une
majorité du peuple dire ce qu'il veut
entendre ne suffit pas dans l'épisode 2
on a vu en particulier que étant donné
les scrutins que l'on utilise
aujourd'hui
pourvu que deux grands partis dominent
le paysage politique
les politiciens ont tout intérêt à se
ranger dans le parti qui leur
correspondent plus plutôt qu'à proposer
des idées ou des combinaisons l'idée
qu'ils sortiraient de la norme qui plus
est ils ont intérêt à constamment se
plaindre des parties déjà au pouvoir a
répété que le pays va man et à prétendre
qu'ils sont la seule alternative à la
médiocrité ambiante
mieux encore s'il pense n'avoir aucune
chance d'acquérir le pouvoir et c'est le
cas de la grande majorité des candidats
de notre scrutin à deux tours pour
rester à la tête de leurs partis
politiques et gagner en influence
les politiciens même intérêt à attirer
l'attention médiatique en proposant des
mesures radicales et en faisant des
promesses irréalistes puisque n'étant
pas élu ils n'auront de toute façon pas
à tenir leurs promesses
et puis dans l'épisode 7 on a vu que les
politiciens ont tout intérêt à concevoir
leurs idées des virus ils ont intérêt à
soutenir des idées faciles à propager à
les rendre suffisamment flexible pour
être réinterprétée par leurs hôtes et
elle est mêlée à la fascination à l'
angoisse à la moquerie et à la colère il
semble même dans leur intérêt d'aborder
des sujets sensibles avec des positions
marquées de sorte à se créer un groupe
de fans inconditionnels mais aussi de
sorte à ce créneau position et a alors
envahir le paysage médiatique avec un
sujet qui divise
pire encore comme on l'a vu dans
l'épisode 6 les électeurs s'isole de
plus en plus dans des filtres bubbles
dont ils ne reçoivent qu'une information
très biaisée
c'est ainsi qu'il pourra même être
préférable pour les politiciens de dire
une chose et son contraire
de sorte que chaque filter bol puisque
thierry pick est ce que le politicien
dit de mieux voir adapter le tir et
picking aux différentes communautés du
web pour faire un gros score au premier
tour et sachant que nos crétins de
cerveau est mais croit vrai ce qui leur
est familier de nos jours plus que
jamais
les politiciens doivent faire le buzz
pour un politicien le pire n'est pas de
se faire des ennemis de s'auto
contredire ou de dire des bêtises
le pire est d'être ignorés encore une
fois je ne suis pas là en train de faire
le procès des politiciens les joueurs
font et vienne ce que j'essaie
modestement de prédire là ce sont les
conséquences du jeu politique tel qu'il
est aujourd'hui et je suis sûr que ma
lecture du jeu politique est très
incomplète et que vous allez vous
empresser de le souligner dans les
commentaires j'espère tout de même vous
avoir donné un aperçu de la perspective
d'un théoricien des jeux qui est je
pense une perspective assez souvent
déficiente
pensez-y a hissé le jeu pas les joueurs
là des enfants on a parlé du principe
fondamental de la politique selon bruce
bennett et mesquita et il y en a
beaucoup parmi vous qui ont fait le lien
avec la théorie de machiavel donc sera
rapidement machiavel était en gros le
premier théoricien de la politique à
penser la politique de manière assez
pragmatique et en considérant que les
hommes ne sont pas des êtres
bienveillants qu'ils font toujours faire
ce qui est bien pour tout le monde
écoeurant pratique la politique c'est
une lutte de pouvoir et que du coup pour
être prince et pour avoir une certaine
stabilité dans son royaume
il fallait ne pas hésiter à être cruel
par moment et d'ailleurs mesquita dans
son bouquin de 10,14 anne boquet aussi
dans le bouquin de logic of political
soda et vol il fait un peu les loges de
machiavel à plusieurs reprises
si vous voulez en savoir plus sur
machiavel jours au moment de la superbe
vidéo de politiken ainsi que la vidéo de
syrie ch'nord raphaël pierre et d'autres
parmi vous dans les commentaires -
demande sur quoi je me reposais pour
dire que les prédictions de mesquita été
plus juste que les avis des experts
alors tout d'abord et ce quitte à lâcher
en lui même est aussi apparemment un
rapport de la nsa qui semble prétendre
en effet les prédictions de mesquita
sont que jusque les avis des experts
alors malheureusement je n'ai jamais
réussi à mettre la main sur ce document
et si vous le trouvez pas n'hésitez pas
l'envoyer vous recommande notamment la
conférence ted que booth me dois de
mesquita a donné au sujet d'une
prédiction sur l'iran et le nucléaire et
dans son bouquin politicians ragoussis à
une chute de featurings mc oui il ya
énormément de prédiction que mesquita
raconte qu'il a fait dans le passé
or il y aurait beaucoup beaucoup
beaucoup pas dire il ya énormément
d'exemples très vivement mais par
exemple dans ce bouquin mesquita raconte
la première prédiction d'un de ses
modèles en 1979 pour l'élection du
premier ministre
en inde il y avait deux grands candidats
et mesquita penser que l'un des deux
grands candidats étaient favoris comme
pas mal d'observateurs de l'époque et en
fait son modèle après direction d'un
tout autre candidat outsider que
personne n'avait vu venir et mesquida
raconte qu'à ce moment là bas croyaient
même que la logique de son modèle était
super fiable
du coup il a quand même publié sa
prédiction et quelques mois plus tard il
se trouve que son algorithme avait
raison et que c'est cet outsider qui a
été élu premier ministre en inde
plus généralement ça fait trente
quarante ans que mes skis tafer soir de
prédiction qu'il a un énorme tracteur
cordes et surtout il a monté une
entreprise qui vend des prédictions et
son entreprise a l'air de très bien se
porter qu'un mec qui a une entreprise
qui fait fortune en ne vendant que des
prédictions fondée sur son algorithme
passé que l'algorithme marche j'ai envie
de dire et pour ceux qui douteraient
encore malgré tout de l'honnêteté
intellectuelle de mesquita notamment la
manière dont il raconte ses prédictions
dans ce livre v un peu quand même
rajouter le fait qu'il est professeur
académique
il a publié des trucs qui sont payés au
viewed qui ont donc été revus par des
pairs et le bouquin de logicoop
politique au soleil vol a été coécrit
avec trois autres auteurs et publié à et
mighty de presse bref ça ressemble quand
même pas mal
un dossier ultra solide qu'est le
dossier de bruce banner de mesquida tony
pèlerins et mick 2048 une demande
comment aligner les incentives pour que
les initiatives des hommes politiques
soient les bons bons initiative c'est
pas clair ce que ça veut dire pour qui
mais plus généralement le principe de la
démocratie représentative c'est
justement ça a cessé d'aligner les
initiatives des politiciens avec la
volonté du peuple et donc contrairement
à ce que je vois beaucoup écrit le
principe de la démocratie représentative
ne absolument pas le fait que le pays
doit être gouverné par un ensemble de
personnes qui est représentatif du
peuple ce qui est censé être
démocratique en démocratie
représentative
c'est surtout le fait que nous
représentants ont des incentive qui sont
alignés avec la volonté du peuple savoir
pour être et rester au pouvoir
les politiciens ont quand même pas mal
tendance à devoir faire ce que le peuple
veut qu'ils fassent alors bien sûr ce
n'est pas tout à fait le cas notamment
parce qu'il ya les lobbys parce que des
gens qui ont une certaine manière plus
de paroles que d'autres des gens qui
passent donc manifeste et du coup font
plus pesé leurs voix que celle de ceux
qui ne manifestent pas typiquement je ne
suis pas en train de défendre la
démocratie représentative en diront que
c'est bien ou assez mal que c'est archi
démocratique ou pas ce que je suis en
train de dire c'est que l'argument selon
lequel la démocratie représentative
ce n'est pas démocratique parce que les
représentants ne sont pas représentatifs
c'est un argument qui est pas tout à
fait celui de ceux qui voudra défendre
la démocratie représentative
victor loewy nous demandent pourquoi
obama a pas essayé de rester au pouvoir
par la force faisant coup d'état où je
sais pas pourquoi il faut voir que il ya
plusieurs niveaux de pouvoir bien sûr il
ya le grand pouvoir qui est un peu le
président qui est sans doute celui qui
est autant france en tout cas
aujourd'hui qu'il a le plus de pouvoir
dans beaucoup de démocratie cependant il
ya aussi les dirigeants des partis est
juste à voir est une personne d'
influence dans un parti un peu rare en
poste de sénateur à tout ça il ya
énormément de degré de pouvoir et un
ancien président a encore beaucoup
d'influx ans une fois qu'il n'est plus
président s'il tente maintenant un coup
d'état
il risque de tout perdre si jamais obama
a tenté de prendre le pouvoir par la
force sans doute qu'ils n'y arriveraient
pas en tout cas le risque d'échec serait
très très très très élevé c'est pour ça
qu obama ne s'est pas cherché à garder
le pouvoir par la force
de la même manière serge denis et al
bahr pense que le fait qu' hollande ne
se soient pas représentés pour la
présidentielle de 2017
un signe que la théorie de mesquita les
fausses non pas du tout les sondages
semblent indiquer que hollande a en ce
moment un record d'impopularité pour un
ancien président donc il ya sans doute
fait les calculs s'est dit que s'il
essayait de se représenter pour la
présidentielle de 2017
alors ils risquaient un échec cuisant
qui lui ferait perdre de l' influence
auprès de son parti et du coup il a
préféré partir dans la dignité ou en
espérant sans doute que plus tard
la roue tourne aurait à nouveau et que
ils se retrouveraient peut-être en cinq
ans je sais pas trop quoi nous
vaud dans des situations où ils
pourraient prétendre à beaucoup de
pouvoir quant à dire qu hollande ça n'a
rien fait pour rester au pouvoir une
fois qu'il a été élu je pense pas que ce
soit vrai c'est juste que le jeu de la
politique est un jeu très difficiles
très compliqué il faut satisfaire à la
fois les électeurs et les lobbys et puis
il ya sans doute été victime d'un
contexte socio-économique au culturel
avec notamment les attaques terroristes
peut-être que si la france avait gagné
l'euro 2016 sourds a été différent
antoine et tony m'ont poussé à elle est
un petit peu le plus loin dans la
description du modèle de mesquita un
point important du modèle de mesquita
c'est que en fait il ya plusieurs degrés
de pouvoir et du coup les politiciens
sont plus ou moins après après accepter
des concessions sur la route au pouvoir
mais qui est possible qu'un politicien
par exemple être président c'est un sur
une échelle de 0 à 100 ça commence
combat sans peut-être que être président
d'un parti c'est 80 pour certains ça
peut être 90 pour d'autres ça peut être
vain pour d'autres il ya des différences
aussi entre les candidats dans les
différents niveaux successifs de pouvoir
il faut prendre tout ça en compte pour
pouvoir faire des modèles et ensuite une
fois que l'on a ça il faut imaginer qu'à
chaque instant chaque politicien va
essayer de convertir d'autres gens
envers eux quoi qu'ils vont essayer
d'influencer les gens avec différents
niveaux de charisme à chaque fois est
typiquement ils vont cibler certaines
stratégies ou aussi de convaincre
certaines personnes d'une certaine
manière pour maximiser son appel
l'espérance
d'utilité c'est à dire ils vont essayer
de voir selon leurs croyances et ce
qu'ils sont capables de faire et selon
les stratégies que les autres personnes
vont adopter à chaque instant ils vont
essayer de maximiser le score moyen
qu'ils auraient selon leurs croyances
alors quand je dis le mot croyances la
seule chose qui est un modèle
probabiliste qu'ils auraient en tête
d'être un modèle bayésiens pour ceux qui
connaissent dont l'aléatoire vient aussi
du fait que les autres individus ont
leurs propres préférences qu'on ne
connaît pas forcément exactement qui
peut avoir des problèmes d'information
incomplète
il peut aussi y avoir de l'incertitude
qui vient du fait que les autres joueurs
peuvent jouer des stratégies mixtes
c'est-à-dire aléatoire reviendra plus
longuement sur certains coups cette
importante de la théorie des jeux
notamment l'utilité lui dit l'espérer
c'est une sorte de stratégie voire
l'information incomplète plus tard dans
cette série serait démocratie mais
malheureusement et je veux m'excuser
j'ai pas prévu de rentrer plus en détail
dans les théories de mesquita pour
plusieurs raisons notamment le fait qu'
il n'y a pas une théorie de mesquita
jusqu'à l'impression que j'ai eu en
lisant ces modèles
malheureusement sont confidentielles
c'est un peu difficile de savoir tout ce
qui s'y passe mais en fait il semblerait
que mesquita réinvente à chaque fois un
modèle qui à chaque fois est assez
distants d'un cas à l'autre
donc à part une théorie de mesquita il
ya plutôt quelques principes
fondamentaux et à chaque fois une
adaptation de ces principes fondamentaux
au cas par cas
à chaque question qui cherche elle
étudie et qui dépend notamment de ce que
disent les experts qui a énormément de
données qui sont fournies par les
experts notamment à quel point tel
candidat est prêt à accepter telle ou
telle concession qui sont vraiment en
fait les données les plus importantes
dans le jeu politique
donc vous pouvez imaginer que plus les
experts donnent beaucoup d'informations
très détaillées vous il faut modifier le
modèle pour prendre tout ça en compte en
particulier au final ça fait des modèles
qui sont souvent un petit peu
moche d'un point de vue élégance
mathématiques en fait mesquida semble
suggérer que le plus important ce n'est
pas vraiment le modèle en tant que tels
que les détails du modèle pour pas avoir
une énorme importance ce qui va vraiment
permettre de progresser par rapport à
l'intuition surtout c'est surtout le
fait de poser un modèle qui soit
conforme au principe fondamental de la
politique et ensuite à a lancé ce modèle
est un voir quelles en sont les
conséquences
bart toutatis nous demandent de quelles
sont les limites du modèle de mesquita
bien sûr vous imaginez qu'en trente
quarante ans de carrière mesquita a fait
quelques productions qui était juste
dans ce livre il parle de quelques
prédictions qui l'a fait qu'ils ne sont
pas justes et ils expliquent pourquoi
ils n'ont pas été justes et un expliqué
quelques limites du modèle notamment
d'irakia qui raconte fièrement un des
politiciens qui avait un rôle majeur à
jouer dans son modèle s'est retrouvé au
coeur d'un scandale sexuel qui n'avait
rien à voir avec la prédiction de prime
abord donc de façon générale tout ce qui
n'est pas dans le modèle et qui a un
effet important risque de complètement
changer des conclusions du modèle saas
et cas pour tout modèle final le prêt
pour être totalement honnête je suspecte
un peu mais ce qui t'a d'avoir choisi
des fausses prédictions dans son bouquin
qui l'arrangé un petit peu dans son
discours salué le bouddha lui fait la
remarque que juste parce que les
prédictions du modèle sont justes ne
veut pas dire que il ce postulat l
hypothèse du modèle sont forcément vrai
et s'ils suivaient bien la vidéo
précédente je n'ai jamais dit ça j'ai
bien tes gars jamais dire qu'il fallait
considérer que les postulats sont vrais
ou indiscutable plus généralement je
crois énormément et la citation de
gordes box tous les modèles sont faux
mais certains sont utiles donc il ne
faut pas voir les modèles de mesquita
comme une description
vrai véritablement vrai indiscutable aux
havrais de la réalité à mon sens la
bonne manière d'interpréter les modèles
de mesquita c'est de voir que ces
modèles sont capables de faire de
meilleures prédictions
donc si on veut faire des prédictions
veut s'intéresser vraiment à la
politique et voir quelles sont les
conséquences des politiques et de
l'élection d'untel ou d'untel vu que la
logique du modèle de mesquita a fait
mieux que la logique de même les experts
de politique il est largement préférable
à mon sens d'essayer de croire le modèle
de mesquida et à sa logique plutôt que
d'essayer de réfléchir par rapport à sa
propre logique ou à sa propre intuition
en particulier je n'exclus pas le fait
qu'un homme politique en particulier
veulent avant tout faire passer une
certaine loi et que c'est sa vraie
fonction d'objectifs mais de toute façon
pour faire passer cette loi il va lui
falloir absolument être et rester au
pouvoir et du coup son comportement pour
en arriver au moment où ils adoptent
cette loi sera indiscernable du
comportement d'un homme politique qu'il
veut juste être et rester au pouvoir
bref les hypothèses du modèle de
mesquita ne sont pas forcément pour est
vrai vrai mais ils sont sans doute
beaucoup plus utile à utiliser pour
faire des prédictions notamment
politiques que tout les intuitions
toutes les idées que l'on pourrait avoir
et en particulier en démocratie la
conséquence de tout ça c'est que dans
une élection présidentielle ce qui
m'intéresse moi personnellement le plus
ce n'est pas ce que dit ce que pensent
qu'elles sont les personnalités ou les
traits physiques moraux les candidats à
la présidentielle ce qui m'intéresse moi
le plus c'est de savoir quelles sont les
électorats de ses différents candidats
et si possible mais c'est plus difficile
à savoir quels sont les lobbys qui les
poussent et les aident à avoir du
financement faire leur campagne
électorale et tout ça enfin jérémy
rouxel me demande si à force de voir le
monde
comme quelque chose de parfaitement
mécanique et tout ça y compris
comportement des individus
je ne déprimez pas à pas du tout moi ça
me fait même plaisir de voir que tout
peut s'expliquer dans un modèle aussi
mécanique
en fait moi à la base la politique ça ne
m'intéresse absolument pas le jour où
j'ai commencé à m'intéresser vraiment à
la politique c'est le jour où j'ai
découvert que la meilleure façon de
décrire et de prédire la politique
c'était de manière parfaitement bécane
inc toutacoo plein de choses se sont
illuminés dans ma tête et c'est là que
j'ai commencé à trouver la politique
intéressante
en fait toute la politique ne
m'intéresse pas quand même qu'il ya
beaucoup de choses en politique je
trouve horriblement ennuyeux par contre
cette logique et sept jeux poétiques qui
peut y avoir et à la manière dont chaque
candidat essaie d'optimiser ses chances
d'être et de rester au pouvoir
ça je trouve ça intéressant alors
clairement je suis assez cynique comme
personne et je trouve en fait qu'il ya
une certaine beauté dans ce cynisme
surtout lorsque à partir de positions
très cynique on en arrive même à une
société qui marche
incroyablement bien si on prend le temps
de prendre trois pas de recul et de
regarder notre société c'est fou à quel
point la société va bien notamment
lorsqu'on sait que tout le monde
économico politique est gouvernée par ce
désir d'être et de rester au pouvoir est
quelque chose d'assez magique
derrière tout ça elle espère qu'ils
avaient mais cette vidéo à faut savoir
que tout a été filmé avant le résultat
du premier tour de l'élection
présidentielle au moment où le film là
je ne sais pas du tout ce qui s'est
passé et de la même façon la prochaine
vidéo a déjà été écrite donc elle sera
indépendante des résultats du premier
tour de l'élection présidentielle la
prochaine vidéo parlera de ce qui à mon
sens est le plus important en politique
en général mais surtout en démocratie en
particulier qui est le fait que nous
nous comportant essentiellement comme
des hooligans politique si vous avez
aimé cet épisode penser à le lac et à le
commenter à le partager pensez à vous
abonner pour ne pas manquer les futurs
épisodes verscio ti peur pour leurs dons
et j'espère que vous serez là la
prochaine fois pensez-y aussi si vous
êtes dans un environnement de travail
qui vous semble compétitif le boulot
c'est souvent un jeu à somme non
constante et c'est pas celui qui
écrasera tous ses adversaires qui
marquera le plus de points à la fin
dec